الوقت عنصر حاسم في
جهود الإنقاذ بعد كارثة كبرى ،
لكننا رأينا رجال الإنقاذ يسحبون الناس من
جميع الأعمار بعد أيام حتى بعد أكثر من
أسبوع من
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا بقوة 7.8 درجة.
حول
المدة التي يمكن للناس أن يعيشوا فيها بعد
زلزال مثل هذا نعرفه من
انهيارات المباني الأخرى
والزلازل الأخرى ، يتم إنقاذ معظم الأشخاص الذين سيتم
إنقاذهم خلال الـ
24 ساعة الأولى ، والحد الأقصى للوقت
للإنقاذ هو 6.8 يومًا
يتحدث فيها الناس غالبًا  حول قاعدة من
أربع دقائق يمكن لأي شخص أن يبقى بدون هواء
لأيام يمكن لشخص ما أن يعيش بدون ماء لمدة
أربعة أسابيع بدون طعام
فكر في الظروف البيئية ،
على سبيل المثال هنا في تركيا كان الجو
باردًا حقًا تحت درجة التجمد من ناحية
عندما يكون الناس باردون حقًا
في الواقع يقلل من مطالبهم
للسوائل عن طريق تقليص جميع
الأوعية الدموية من ناحية أخرى ،
يمكن أن تجعل الظروف شديدة البرودة من الصعب
على شخص ما البقاء على قيد الحياة
كما كان انهيار المبنى كما لو
كان نوعًا من الانهيار الفطري حيث
سقطت جميع الأرضيات على بعضها البعض  من غير
المحتمل أن تحصل على أي نوع من الفراغات من الهواء
أو الماء ، هل حوصر شخص ما
في منطقة يوجد بها طعام
أو ماء مثل المطبخ أو
سوق الطعام ، رأينا أشياء مثل هذه تحدث في
هايتي ، فهناك كل أنواع الأشياء الجديدة
التقنيات والاستخدام فقط
للكلاب التي يمكن أن تساعد في العثور على الأشخاص
بسرعة أكبر ، الأشخاص الأصغر سنًا
الذين ليس لديهم ظروف موجودة مسبقًا ،
الأشخاص الأكثر
لياقة بدنيًا والذين كانوا أكثر
رطوبة في الوقت الذي
حدث فيه الانهيار بالفعل ، هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين  من
المرجح أن يظلوا على قيد الحياة ، لكننا
رأينا أشخاصًا في السبعينيات من العمر يتم
إنقاذهم فعليًا بعد عدة أيام رأينا
قصة طفل تعرض للجرح من
النافذة أثناء انهيار فطيرة يُعتقد
أنه مات ولكن تم إنقاذه بالفعل بواسطة Good
Samaritans  يعمل بشكل جيد اليوم
أجنبي ،
لذلك هناك هذه القصص الرائعة لأشخاص
نجوا ، وهذا هو السبب في أن العديد من
الأيام حتى الآن بعد الزلزال لا
يزالون في وضع الإنقاذ على عكس
وضع الاسترداد في العديد من الأماكن في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، وقد يتغير ما حدث هنا في
تركيا  كم من الوقت يستمر رجال الإنقاذ في
البحث كما ترون
الأشخاص الذين نجوا لعدة أيام
حتى بعد بعض هذه
الانهيارات الصعبة حقًا
[تصفيق]